the elderscrolls speak of the past and
the future
now Skyrim looks to the future to its
ultimate version Alexa play Skyrim
you're a level 57 and see a tall snowy
mountain climate now Skyrim and life
become one a mud crabs cuddles tore this
lid off I didn't catch that
race Wow I didn't quite catch this all
the way to so Vanguard what happened
FUS ro dah that's the command for
knocking things over is there a command
for picking [ __ ] up ever reached that
level yet I'm sworn to carry your
burdens oh the dragon unleashes fire
breath on you okay you have 7% health
left oh [ __ ] I drink a health potion you
are out of health potions Oh
how many wheels of cheese do I have left
473 can i eat all the cheese I eat all
of the season
hey hon um remember what the doctor said
about dairy yes right yes of course
you're the greatest
thank you so much I ate
introducing Skyrim very special edition
also coming soon to HS sketch Motorola
pagers and your Samsung smart
refrigerator east sled goose oh that's
cool
Oh
[Music]